[музика]
вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі Ми раді що ви
приєдналися до нас дедалі більше людей
ризикують своїм життям і вирушають у
небезпечні подорожі у пошуках нового
життя в Європі за даними Організації
Об'єднаних Націй лише цього року понад
180 000 людей прибули до Європи через
Середземне море інші використовували
наземні шляхи щоб дістатися до кордонів
Європейського Союзу Минулого року було
майже мільйон біженців які шукали
прихистку багато з них також хотіли
привести свої сім'ї Усі вони сподівалися
на краще майбутнє
тут зростання кількості біженців створює
проблеми для європейських країн Бельгія
наприклад намагається впоратись зі
значним напливом мігрантів у столиці
брюселі жителі дедалі частіше
натрапляють на чоловіків які сплять на
вулицях невиконання державою своїх
зобов'язані і відмова надавати житло
чоловікам які шукають прихистку призвело
до такої ситуації як наслі
потерпілі висловлюють свої протести
Робін Родріго як і багато інших змушений
спати просто неба із наближенням зими у
Європі ці люди починають втрачати
впевненість у своєму
майбутньому Світанок у бельгійській
столиці 47річний Робін Родріго зі
шрі-ланки вже кілька тижнів спить просто
неба прямо біля бельгійського офісу з
питань надання прихистку Він чекає на
розгляд своєї
заяви просив Надати мені житло а він
відповів що зараз у нас немає вільних
місць бо в Україні дуже багато людей і
сказав спати на підлозі і я сплю на
підлозі не маючи куди йти Він чекає тут
як і десятки інших Робін спостерігає як
щоранку о 8:30 брюссельський центр з
питань надання прихистку відкривається
на півгодини жінки діти та сім'ї
шикуються у чергу ліворуч самотні
чоловіки праворуч Бельгія надає
прихистокжі і дітямбіженцям їх негайно
вивозять звідси але із жовтня 2021 року
чоловікам які прибувають по одинці житло
не надається їх відсилають назад з
анкетами у яких їм пропонують записатися
в уже переповнений список очікування
допомагають їм лише Волонтери які
приходять
щоранку цим хлопцям нічого робити нічого
їсти нікуди
йти але згідно із бельгійським
законодавством Влада зобов'язана
надавати прихисток і їжу цим людям а
вони вирішили не дотримуватись закону їм
байдуже біженцям залишається тільки
чекати як на сратула він був солдатом
афганської армії до відходу західних
військ чоловік прибув до Бельгії три
місяці тому рятуючись від талібів в
Афганістані Моя ситуація дуже кепська
погляньте на це я живу в наметі з трма
людьми чотирма людьми п'ятьма людьми ми
разом живемо в цьому наметі погода
дощова наша ситуація дуже скрутна після
закриття офісу з питань надання
прихистку о 9т ранку люди розходяться на
цілий день сильна католицька Віра Робіна
приводить його до брюсельського
кафедрального собору він молиться щоб
знайти вихід із цієї
[музика]
ситуації
чоловік не бачив свою дружину і двох
маленьких дітей уже три роки
Робін розповідає що його речі вкрали і в
нього більше немає
паспорта я хочу перевести сюди мою сім'ю
Коли я отримаю візу то зможу забрати
своїх двох дітей і дружину тоді я хотів
би залишити їх тут мені подобається
допомагати людям але я не маю грошей Але
у нього все ще є сертифікати які він
отримав працюючи кваліфікованим
зварювальником на важких будівельних
роботах він працював в Іраку у 2005 та
2010 роках у катарі та півтора року у
Румунії за даними благодійної
організації для біженців
флюхтлінгенверк середній час розгляду
прохання про надання прихистку у Бельгії
становить 440 днів відповідно до
законодавства ЄС люди мають право на
житло на час очікування і флюхт
лінгенверк вважає це всеєвропейською
проблемою
це справжня гонитва до дна в усьому
Європейському Союзі Якщо говорити про
спільну систему нададня прихистку
наприклад коли кожна країна трохи гірша
за сусідню країну тому що вона хоче бути
менш привабливою Тож у певному сенсі це
частина загальної європейської політики
бути найменш привабливою
країною у Бельгії Є список очікування на
житло для самотніх чоловіків які
скоротили до 2700 імен тож принаймні
стільки людей сплять під відкритим не ще
сотні людей не можуть навіть потрапити
до цього списку внутрішні бельгійські
суди 8 000 разів виносили рішення проти
уряду за недотримання права на прийом
так само як і Європейський суд з прав
людини виносив рішення проти Бельгії
понад 1700 разів ми отримали письмову
відповідь із офісу держсекретаря Бельгії
відповідального запитання надання
прихистку згідно з цим листом Бельгія
зіткнулася зі збільшенням кількості
Запитів на прихисток у 2022 році на 40%
порівняно з 2021 роком і при нинішніх
345тисях місць мережа пунктів прийому
біженців у Бельгії ще ніколи не була
такою великою щоб підтримати цих
бездомних чоловіків благодійні
організації почали винаймати приміщення
подібні до цієї колишньої офісної
будівлі у брюселі 350 чоловіків
переважно з Бурунді судану еритреї та
Ємену живуть тут фабріс дюпї очолює
команду з 15 осіб і що дня йому
доводиться відмовляти близько 20
новоприбулим таким як цей
чоловік Сьогодні у нас немає вільного
місця я ж не можу розмістити цих людей
ось
так відносно нещодавно потрапивши у Це
коло бездомності та очікування Робін все
ще переконаний що майбутнє його сім'ї
тут у Європі це мій син Кевін а це моя
донька дуксі а це я і він продовжує
чекати з кожним днем все більше більше
чоловіків сплять у проходах біля
бельгійського офісу з питань надання
прихистку життя тут зараз дуже важке А
ще навіть не
зима закордонні представництва Китаю
розглядаються як інструмент впливу
пекіна в Європі керівництво Китаю
жорстко розправляється з критиками
режиму зокрема із тими хто втік в
еміграцію
фінлау який живе в Лондоні роками
невтомно виступає за свободу слова і
демократі на свой
батьківщині китайський уряд запропонував
винагороду за інформацію яка може
сприяти його арешту гонконський активіст
не почувається в безпеці навіть в
еміграції Свобода для Гонконгу з
еміграції в Лондоні фінлао бореться за
демократію у своїй рідній країні
незважаючи на те що уряд Гонконгу
пропонує винагороду в розмірі понад 100
000 євро за його
упіймання
цей спланований крок схоже прикріплює
цінник до мого життя а також мого
непохитного прагнення до
демократії Це відверта транснаціональна
репресія яка має на меті придушити всіх
голоси які виступають за демократію в
усьому
світі Влада Гонконгу хоче заарештувати
30тирічного чоловіка і віддати його під
суд у Гонконзі вони стверджують що
фінлау і сім інших активістів підривні
елементи які співпрацюють із іноземними
урядами щоб проникнути в
державу Ми хочемо повернути нашу долю Ми
хочемо повернути нашу свободу повернути
наше право на демократію і
самовизначення Гонконг має особливий
адміністративний статус із моменту його
передачі від Великобританії до Китаю у
1997 році він ґрунтується на доктрині
Одна країна дві ми але цей принцип дає
тріщини Пекін посилює свій вплив чтири
роки тому сотні тисяч людей з Гонконгу
вийшли на вулиці на демонстрацію проти
втручання пекіна
фінлау геодезист за фахом був тоді одним
із лідерів він провів два дні під вартою
в поліції після чого втік до
Великобританії колишньої колоніальної
держави зараз у Лондоні протестує лише
невелика репрезентативна група людей у
само Гонконзі Навряд чи хтось наважиться
публічно критикувати китайський
уряд після
1997 року ми стали свідками системної
ерозії нашої Свободи а також демократії
та автономії зараз у гонконгських
в'язницях відбувають покарання понад
1600 політичних в'язнів
фінлау говорить про залякування навіть в
еміграції в лондоні він обережний вважає
що цілком імовірно що його мо спробувати
викрасти Він розповідає про випадок що
трапився Незадовго після його прибуття
до Британії коли його жорстко побила
група
незнайомців британський Уряд не хоче
видавати фіналау а Міністр закордонних
справ Великобританії заявив що не буде
терпіти жодних спроб залякати і змусити
людей мовчати ми неодноразово зверталися
до посольства Китаю в Лондоні із
проханням про коментар але так і не
отримали відповіді чай на Таун Епіцентр
китайської громади Лондона Навряд чи
хтось тут захоче коментувати ситуацію в
Гонконзі це надто делікатне питання ті
хто все ж висловлює свою думку як
правило підтримують китайський уряд та
його вплив у
Гонконзі Гонконг безумовно повинен мати
право самостійно приймати рішення це
правда через окрему
політику Але я вважаю що Гонконг - це
невід'ємна частина
Китаю економіка Гонконгу насправді
доволі га останніми роками тож це добре
для жителів Гонконгу і для людей на
материку теж це певний
зв'язок Дисиденти бачать це по-іншому і
проводять марш прямо посеред шайнатауну
фінлау закликає британський уряд
накласти санкцій на гонконських
чиновників і економічно дистанціюватись
від
[оплески]
Китаю вони можуть голосно говорити про
проблему Гонконгу але в той же час У нас
є деякі мініст чи можливо інші люди які
прагнуть більшої співпраці з Китаєм що
збільшить нашу залежність від
китайського
ринку Я б сказав що ми повинні
відмовитися від такого суперечливого
підходу у Лондоні фінлау та інші
активісти можуть публічно висловлювати
свої думки перед китайським посольством
вони мріють що одного дня це стане
можливим і в
Гонконзі
для італійського Кравця одягати найвищу
особу католицької церкви це безперечно
велика честь папа францискик і багато
інших церковних достойників обирає
вбрання від дизайнера і багатогранного
таланта філіпо сорчинелі з Риму він гей
вкритий татуюваннями і надзвичайно
модний і Хоч він і не зовсім вписується
в традиційний образ Ватикану йому
вдається займати ключову
створені вбрання для католицької
церкви Собор Святого Петра філіпо
сорчинелі виготовляє одяг для деяких
найважливіших релігійних діячів світу
його палантини ризи і головні убори для
єпископів користуються великим попитом у
всьому ватикані замовлення надходять від
кардиналів єпископів і навіть
Пап замовлення для Папи Римського робить
офіс тургіних урочистостей Верховного
архієрея коли надходить замовлення я
починаю працювати над
дизайном потім роблю кілька пропозицій
папським співробітникам а вони роблять
свій
вибір магазин філіппо знаходиться в Римі
прямо на кордоні Ватикану однак це не
Модний бутік Він каже що його одяг це не
мода а вбрання для
вічності
580 так і білу ризу з
Христом мій стиль натхненний ранніми
часами
церкви коли значення мав не стільки
орнамент скільки
символіка його творіння виробляється у
сантарже недалеко від
Ріміні сорчинелі зазвичай використовує
шовк або вовну потім його команда
прикрашає вироби релігійною вишивкою усе
вручну що вирізняє його роботу це увага
до найменших
[музика]
деталей тут ми працюємо над останніми
деталями ризи для важливого
клієнта ця центральна частина багато
вишита
у такому ж стилі ми орнаментуємо всі
краї для папи Франциска Філіпу виготовив
близько 20 вбрань а для покійного папи
Бенедикта X понад 50 зокрема і цю
митру і ту в який Бенедикт був на
державному похованні у базиліці Святого
Петра стиль папи Бенедикта базувався на
витоках церкви на
традиціях стиль Папи Франциска мало чим
відрізняється він трохи простіший трохи
легший і можливо трохи менш зухвалий ніж
стиль папи Бенедикта
філіпо витрачає до тисячі годин роботи
на деякі зі своїх рис ціни на них
коливаються від 1000 до 7 000 євро і
сьогодні священник Дон Габріела підбирає
собі нову
ризу вона така гарна і легка її можна
вдягати як на звичайну службу так і на
урочисту
церемонію сорчинелі також пропонує цілу
низку різних виробів які не призначені
для
кардиналів у сусідній крамниці Він
продає одеколони з такими назвами як тус
Петрус cyберсex або
crкisinga вони призначені для римської
гей
католицькі покупці по сусідству здається
не мають нічого проти церква має бути
привітною вона не може нічого цуратися і
бути відкритою для всіх аспектів нашого
суспільства дивитися на все без страху
бо це також частина християнського
послання для Філіпа його Віра і
сексуальна орієнтація не суперечать одне
одному а
[музика]
навпаки Караваджо Мікеланджело Леонардо
да Вінчі та багато інших митців показали
нам що творіння краси перемагає все і
церква не засуджує таких
[музика]
людей у своєму прагнені до краси та
високого мистецтва філіпо знайшов спосіб
зміцнити свою
[музика]
віру ви коли-небудь бачили щоб діти так
раділи шкільному обіду особливо коли в
ньому багато овочів що ж діти у цій
французькій школі отримують надзвичайно
здорову їжу І до того ж повністю
органічну
мансарту- невелике містечко на півдні
Франції із населенням трохи більше 10
000 жителів і мабуть одне із найбільш
екологічно чистих місць в
країні у Відні кав'ярні мають давні
традиції у 2011 році культура кав'ярень
Відня навіть була визнана культурною
спадщиною Юнеско тож щоб дійсно
вирізнятися як ресторатор серед усіх цих
кав'ярень потрібно щось унікальне та
особливе Крістіан таус зробив саме це
він інтегрував своє нетрадиційне хобі у
свою професію історичні ліфтові кабіни
роблять концепцію його кав'ярні особливо
унікальною
час випити кави адже на цьому Ми
завершуємо випуск Європа У фокусі цього
тижня Дякуємо за перегляд Бережіть себе
і до наступної
[музика]
зустрічі
Y